[Musique]
pour vacciner plus vite et plus fort
le gouvernement va déployer des
vaccinodromes des centres de vaccination
géante
la vaccination est une priorité
nationale il n'y a pas de jours fériés
il n'y a pas de week-end pour la
vaccination est donc nous devons dans
tous les centres de vaccination qui sont
ouverts sur le sol national vacciner au
maximum dans les locaux de ce syndicat
du premier degré la vaccination des
enseignants c'est la revendication
numéro un
les chiffres sont là en comparant les
contaminations des deux dernières
semaines les courbes s'envole 80
structures scolaires fermés à ce jour
2018 las il n'en avait que entre
guillemets 833 il y a une semaine
il n'y a pas de trêve il n'y en aura pas
jusqu'au bout
faye a pas de vaccin donc moi je veux
bien on peut prendre des décisions peut
annoncer tout ce qu'on veut ils ont mis
en place une usine à gaz pour les
vaccins n'y a pas de vaccins suffisant
l'étudiant en médecine de 24 ans a été
retrouvé mort chez lui dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi par les pompiers sur
place ils trouvent un document attestant
que le jeune interne au chu de nantes
avait reçu une injection d'astrazeneca
dix jours plus tôt ce qui est nouveau
c'est ce qu'on appelle des
thrombophlébite cérébrale qui
s'accompagne de troubles de la
coagulation
ça reste rare on est sur une vingtaine
de cas sur l'europe pour 20 millions de
personnes qui ont reçu le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
néanmoins c'est sûr venus
majoritairement chez des femmes et chez
des gens de moins de 50 ans ce qui fait
que la recommandation aujourd'hui de la
haute autorité de santé et de donner le
vaccin d'astrazeneca au plus tôt street
55 ans il ne faut pas se contenter de ce
qui est prévu
mais ouvrir les vaccins on sait qu' il
ya eu des débats sur astrazeneca qui à
mon avis vont laisser des traces qu'on
le veuille ou pas ça va laisser des
traces
donc je pense qu'il est de plus en plus
urgent d'ouvrir à d'autres vaccins je
pense aux vaccins russe mais pas
seulement
la vaccination est bien entendu un choix
volontaire de chaque personne
une décision personnelle à ce propos et
j'ai l'intention de me faire vacciner
demain c'est l'union européenne qui a
négocié pour nous le nombre de doses et
les délais de livraison et on voit bien
que ça marche pas
l'idéologie qui fait comme l'a dit
monsieur breton commissaire européen ce
week-end eh bien on refuse d'acheter des
vaccins à la russie ce qu'a dit thierry
breton pour être précis c'est que le
moment où le vaccin russe sera
vraisemblement validées scientifiquement
et on pourrait faire appel à lui c'est
le mois de juin en gros c'est le début
de l'été et à ce moment là nous aurons
suffisamment d'autres doses de vaccins
dont on entend dire la même chose du
futur vaccin français on en aura pas
besoin quand il va arriver non plus m
quand nous entendons de tels propos de
la part de diplomates
on peut se demander quels sont les
intérêts protégés si ceux des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques ou ceux des
européens face à la pandémie
le gouvernement un nouveau slogan hier
soir le premier ministre dévoile un
document intitulé deux dents avec les
miens dehors en citoyen 11
recommandations l'accompagnent sur le
couvre feu ou encore sur le télétravail
en fumée c'est à dire que il est
incompréhensible pour nos concitoyens
2dans avec les miens je veux bien mais
alors dehors en citoyen c'est c'est tout
sauf limpide on en sourit ou qu'est ce
qu'on trouvait oui oui oui on en souffre
à tous m'ont fait rire on en sourit
parce que c'est pas salé il ya des
discours de communication qui font
sourire celui celui là fait sourire on
s'en fout des slogans faut dire c'est
pas ça le sujet quand enfin il ya les
français pour des idiots ils ont
parfaitement compris sont mis à combien
pour trouver un slogan c'est ridicule
dedans avec les miens quoi faire à ce
que tout ça est incompréhensible et
stupide
il faut de l'ordre et de la méthode qui
en fait tout ça masque une réalité c'est
que confinement couvre-feu mettez-y démo
vous voulez sur la situation qu'on vit
aujourd'hui on a patrie c'est pas les
bons à rien qui sont juste capable de
flanquer des amendes à tout le monde de
faire des gardes à vue qui vont nous
expliquer ce qu'on doit faire à
marseille parce qu'ils sont discrédités
à nos yeux